freunde seht ihr dass diese neuen
gemälde
nein ich auch nicht ja ich bin seit zwei
monaten in dieser tracks wohnung und
habe es nicht geschafft ein einziges
bild aufzuhängen so langsam finde ich
könnte mein zimmer schon mal ein
bisschen wohnlicher werden wie bei allen
anderen kreativen sachen die ich gemacht
habe meine nummer eins anlaufstelle
sobald ich
vielen dank an den fokus der mir immer
wieder zur seite steht münchen brauchen
aber natürlich brauchen auch noch ein
paar dinge um diese bilder machen zu
können wir waren jetzt gerade schon
einkaufen in seinem laden der mega
krasses und diesen ganzen kram verkauft
und jetzt haben wir ein paar acrylfarben
ein bisschen sprühfarbe und das sollte
eigentlich schon reichen also wir uns
dafür entschieden jetzt nichts zu machen
sondern zu machen daraus dem grund gut
weil ich weniger schlecht verpacken kann
also man möchte farben zusammen mit so
einem verdünnung zahlt die farben
flüssiger werden und dann schüttet man
auch die rahmen- drauf und dann verläuft
das einfach dann gibt es ein paar
verschiedene sachen die man auf der rein
machen kann und dann verläuft das in
verschiedene richtungen diese kamera ist
mir würde zum dritten mal runterfallen
prinzip möchte man die farben einfach
zusammen dann kommt dieses zeug hier
rein und dann tut man das auch ein
ganzer fließt das video zu ende
und nun man den rest macht wissen wir
selber nicht ein probieren so genau
wissen was wir tun konsistent sind
eigentlich sind mit was hat auch extrem
geil aussehen würde fetziger besser als
einfach so und dann runter dass
verbraucher standarten aber als erstes
zusammenschnitten nicht wahr ist war
schon so als könnten wir das so macht
uns jetzt so in den mittel also man ja
ja genauso also man tut die man tut die
leinwand teil strom auf den becher und
dann wird man auch drei ganzen um 1 33
es ist genau so wie es sein soll es
sieht genauso aus um ein paar senat und
zu den becher überhaupt noch bewegen
oder wird sie mir einfach gut leben und
dann machen dann selbst verlaufen
[Musik]
ich habe noch nie so etwas schönes
gesehen und mein leben komplett
persönlich sich ein alter genauso wie es
aus dem st man kann einfach auf uns
hören dass solche anleitungen geben
ich habe halt bei mir noch spiele
gemacht ich habe gesehen dass es gut
sein soll auch das dann cool ist werden
beim kicken kann auf jeden fall noch mal
richtig viel beeinflussen was hingeht wo
das hier ist aufgegangen ist gerade
jetzt in die richtung das ist genauso
wie schon vorgestellt das aber das wird
wahrscheinlich nämlich nicht genug
bekommen das mittelmeer fahren
eigentlich eher zu viel als nehmen
für den ersten versuch scheint das schon
ziemlich gut zu funktionieren
ich lass einfach komplett in eine
richtung
[Musik]
u
niebels geil es kommt leider auf der
kamera nicht so mega gut überall so geil
sind schön zu haben wenn man dann so
eine einzelne bereiche geben kann ohne
dass alles sich die ganze zeit zu wirken
oder man postet das habe ich auch ein
paar videos die ich auch endlich haben
die sind ja ich kann es das ist kein
zerlaufen honig perfekt
das weiß das auch
nachdem es bei audi jetzt dreimal sehr
gut funktioniert hat und bei mir zweimal
ergebnisse herausgekommen sind
eigentlich nicht so aussehen sollten wir
jetzt ein letztes mal das vernünftig so
ein vorletztes mal scheint sich noch
nicht ab wir brauchen dann funktioniert
das lasse ich war es entgegen
von j
der schein trügt gehe ich über die
länder oder lassen
ich glaube ich hier auch einfach auf
aber meine künstlerin in der grundschule
hat immer gesagt dass wir keine freien
weißen sachen an der seite
ja geil sieht gut aus wir sehen sind
immer gut dann kann ich einen blöden was
nun
der verlorene sohn des verlorenen bild
das ich nach dem ich nicht mehr wusste
was ich machen soll jetzt scheiße aus
einfach mit dem spatel 15 mal drüber
gezogen hat
ok
aber ich glaube hier gehe ich über den
rand wieder aus dem kopf zu kaufen
500 euro ja soll ich sagen
ja geil was die ausrichtung dieses
vorhaben ist nichts sagen
die können klassische enthaltung david
haye
hier wollte ich den zuschauer noch sehr
viel freiraum für eigene gedanken lasse
endlich ist die weißen wollen mit der
studie aber viele zuschauer kommt ja
immer schlauer von meiner idee ja das
sind die bilder die wir haben sind
[Musik]
ich bedanke mich natürlich bei audi die
mir dabei geholfen dass ich nicht
komplett scheiße aussieht